i just want to go see the spelman house
you know just as an
actor i wish that i had gotten the
chance to like say goodbye to the
character and everybody
like i think that's what everybody wants
is just to see these characters
um just live their lives and be okay
um and i think you that's just uh up to
up to the beholder that you've gotta
just know that
that all these kids are just gonna be
witchy and weird and scarred for life
and that's gonna be wonderful so let's
finish this the way we always do
together
[Music]
so first off roz is a witch i repeat roz
is a witch oh my gosh jazz when you
found this
out what was your reaction and what was
it like joining the spellbinding side of
things well
i wasn't cool about it it wasn't casual
it wasn't subtle everybody had to hear
about it i was freaking
pumped because i've been wanting to be a
witch
forever in my real life and then
obviously since like day one on sabrina
um so that was actually a dream come
true and i had my harry potter moment in
the kitchen in the kitchen with skye
and nana walker where they're like
you're a wizard harry
you know so i was like geeking out all
day outside it was amazing
not only a witch but a weird sister what
was it like to step into that role
oh it was so fun it was i loved and it
was so quick
unfortunately that that whole thing was
quick but uh
me and skye and tati's scenes were some
of my favorite to shoot
the whole series it was just electric
when we got to do scenes together it was
amazing
i can't do it alone would you have in
mind
well lachlan i'm loving your look right
now this is awesome
i'm like a little soccer angel i love it
um we've got to talk about theo
watching theo's journey throughout the
course of chilling adventures of sabrina
has been so inspiring and and just
fans have been rooting for this
character this entire time
what was the most rewarding part for you
of theo's journey in part four
i think a rewarding part for theo was
for theo to find love like i think
that's the the cheesy little happy story
that we don't always get to see with
queer people like they always have to
have a hard time and like
did do tragedy but it was so nice to
just have some really
awesome beautiful human moments with
theo and i feel like that was really
rewarding
off screen it was so rewarding every
single part
to um scroll through my instagram dms
and see all these beautiful wonderful
little like non-binary or queer or
different in any way
actors who would send me these gorgeous
paragraphs about how
they were so inspired that you know they
felt like they didn't have a place in
the industry
and that seeing a non-binary actor or
seeing
a theo on screen really helped them keep
with it and that makes me so happy so
the whole thing the whole the whole
journey was really really rewarding and
i can't wait to take
all of that energy with me robin are you
really gonna stay in greendale
why would i leave unfortunately the
series is ending after part four
and that was not the original plan but
so how are you guys feeling knowing that
the end of part four is now serving as
the series finale
jazz i'm in my feelings about it i'm
gonna be honest
um i just wanna go see my friends in
vancouver i just want to go see the
spelman house you know
just as an actor i wish that i had
gotten the chance to like say goodbye to
the character and everybody
um but as far as like the actual show
goes and what we're releasing
i think we have a really really good
material and i think people are gonna be
really excited about it because
this part really found its flow and its
groove and
um is exciting and dramatic enough to
finish such a cool show i think
i mean it can't be all out all the time
it's not all hell i'm very curious to
know though do you guys think
that some kind of a sabrina wrap up
movie or some kind of iteration could
exist in the future have you heard
anything lachlan
i would be surprised if roberto is
already not trying to make that happen
because that would be a very roberto
thing to do and i am on board
i think he would make like a disney like
a disney channel original movie and
that's
like crossover like like harvey goes to
rome
he doesn't make it like he doesn't even
need permission he can just do it and
just have
like all these weird like katy keen
sabrina riverdale like just
so who knows who knows what goes on in
that beautiful man's brain
that we can finally have the crossovers
that we were waiting this whole time
for begging for oh well speaking of that
what was still
on your sabrina bucket list what was
something that you wanted to see for
theo and raws that you didn't quite get
a chance to
lock lean on kick us off ah i mean i'm
forever jealous that jazz got magical
powers um
because i think that's just so cool uh
we all did have some
some some conjuring moments towards the
end that we all got to pile on with so i
think
i i don't think i could ask for anything
more i just you know i would want to see
theo blossom like i think that's what
everybody wants is just to see these
characters
um just live their lives and be okay
um and i think you that's just uh up to
the up to the beholder that you've gotta
just know that
that all these kids are just gonna be
witchy and weird and
scarred for life and that's gonna be
wonderful seriously and jazz how about
you
i felt so satisfied with everything that
ross did i mean who she started off as
doing the student council thing the
wicked thing being blind
you know being a witch a seer falling in
love
being mad being a cheerleader like a
musician
whatever like i don't see how i could
possibly ask for any more
out of this character i really really
got to do so much
um i would just be curious to see where
honestly what the next theme would be
because that's one of my favorite parts
is that the parts
are themed so i would just be curious to
know what part 5's theme would have been